jessica is in lancaster pennsylvania hi
jessica how are you
i'm doing great dave thank you for
taking my call it's an honor to speak to
you
you too what's up so um i
have a question about some inheritance
that i received when my dad passed away
um my sister was purposefully written
out of the will
and i have always wanted to i think it's
the right thing to share something with
her but
i don't agree with the way she's
financially lived her life and the
decisions she's made
so i do not want to give her cash the
decision i made was to have some money
set aside for
wedding whenever she gets married and to
make a one-time
principal payment on her student loan
that she's been carrying and
she now thinks it's a waste for me to
make that
payment and she thinks you'll agree with
her which i know you won't
um why was she why was she cut out of
the wheel
um the relationship between her and my
dad fell apart years ago and
i believe my dad's stubbornness led it
to not
getting repaired okay
that's so sad yeah yes i know how long
has he been gone
five years how old are you and how old
is she
i'm 46 and she's 43. and um and
obviously you guys have a pretty good
relationship
yes we do okay and how much money are
you talking about
i i want to make a 20 000
payment towards your student loan and
out of how much money did you receive
um i think about 150 total okay
all right there's a part of you that is
act feels somewhat maternal towards her
that you don't trust her to make good
decisions
and so you're gonna you're gonna give
her so you're gonna give her a gift
because it's the right thing to do but
you're gonna direct how it
if if it feels like a weird relational
dynamic for between sisters is
is is that she's responsible with money
right
um is that is there discomfort there
between the two of you said she was
gonna say
that was a waste of a gift well
yes because the direction she's going is
she's uh she's not doing anything to pay
it off with any urgency she's just
riding it out
until it gets to 25 years thinking the
balance will be
forgiven because of an income-based
repayment plan
and what i'm offering to give her and
what she would pay over the next
13 years so that happens would not total
the
total balance of the loan
okay well there's a lot of things going
on here
um first let's just talk about the
public service
student loan forgiveness program as of
today
the last night i'm sorry she's not even
public service
loan forgiveness why does she feel oh
she just feels like in general it's
going to be forgiven
yes she found something online that says
the the income based repayment plan when
the loan is
at 25 years the balance will be forgiven
it hasn't been so far 227 000 people
have applied for student loan
forgiveness under these programs
3 700 out of 200 000 have gotten it
that's less than one percent
and so um her she's um
uh she believes a lie about
getting out of student loan debt so
that's that's one piece of information
so in that sense um
you know we we've got other problems
with her student loan
other than whether you give her money or
whether she pays it off
because that student loan's not going
away unless the biden administration and
the
democratic congress decides to forgive
student loan debt which is possible
for the first time in our history um and
uh uh you know there's
obviously a lot of uh rhetoric in the
last uh
four or five months uh since the
inauguration about that so
and there's no way to predict what they
will actually do or if they will do
anything other than just talk about it
you know their congress so um
um
normally so
normally in a situation like this i i
want to
give because it's something that i think
is the right thing to do
and it always is hard when you come up
against this moment when you think
by by giving the right thing to do i'm
going to enable somebody to hurt
themselves further
is that where you're at jessica or you
just don't like how she's spending it
yeah if i don't want to enable her bad
behavior because she's
obviously not going to put it towards
the loan it will
most likely get at least somewhat wasted
and spent
uh and i really want to really want to
help her
yeah if um
yeah is there if we could take the
student loan out of the thing it would
change the equation for me i mean does
she have a car loan or something you can
just pay off
no she doesn't uh this is her only dad
this is her own this is her only dad
is this her only debt as far as i know
yes
okay
and the interesting thing is as you all
have talked about it to where the
language has changed to where now she
feels entitled to it
i know i'm entitled to tell you what to
do with the money you're giving her that
was interesting part of the
thing too yeah so wow
i don't know what to tell you i um i
think i
you know here's an idea when in doubt
don't and just say
you know what i want to do something
to honor you out of this inheritance
because i think you've got a raw deal
but i also don't want to participate in
a delusional situation and your student
loan's not i don't think your student
loan is going away
and so how much does she owe
i think 92 and what does she make
she makes now about 60. okay
um you know i i
might offer to match her
for every five thousand dollars she puts
on you'll put five thousand on it
um i like that idea but um but but
but you know and it's just it's just you
and her talking and you're just saying
i you know you're an adult you have the
right to do what you want to do
sister but but i
also have that and i i cannot give you
money for i agree with you that giving
you money for this is going to end up
being wasted because you're not going to
get it paid off and then it's going to
be a bigger problem
because you you think it's going to go
away i don't think it's going to go away
so i really don't want to put the 20 on
that and so i don't know how to give you
money
because you're miss because i think what
you're doing with this is irresponsible
and so i love you and i want you to win
and so what we're going to do right now
is nothing i'm just going to sit back
and watch a little bit
and and if you decide you want to get
after the student loan
and i'll put some money towards it with
you and i'll help you but
until you do i right now i'm just going
to watch because i want to do something
but i don't know how to do it right now
and so
what i'm going to do is wait okay
and in the meantime should i do
something different with it other than
it's just sitting in my face
account of the bank yeah well you can do
whatever you want i mean it's not it's
it you can put in a mutual fund if you
want then you can pull it out and give
it to her but
um later on but it's just the biggest
thing here is it's just
all tied back to this heartbreaking
relationship between
her and your dad yeah that's the part i
don't like about it dave is it
because dad did what he did
now she's holding this and she's gotta
make one of two choices
either i'm going to become dad and i'm
going to
use my relational position
and my money to keep you and not share
it with you because of your decisions
your choices
so i'm replaying what just happened oh
that's true or
i'm going to give you money knowing that
i'm just throwing this
i'm throwing in the wind that's right
and so my impulse um
there's always wisdom and they just just
it's just do nothing that's all i said
yeah
and then my thought is you know what i'm
saying i'm gonna
free myself from this and so i it's the
same impulse just the other side
which if you feel in your heart's the
right thing dad did a raw deal the right
thing is to give money the right thing
to do is to give money
and forget it don't worry yeah and
that's what i wanted it's not on you
well it drills down to if someone's if
someone's doing drugs someone's hurting
themself versus they're going to go buy
a dumb car
right but man especially when you're
holding that money you could really help
them with their student loan
it's hard just a messy situation there's
a 41 year old
yeah so it might be down to what you're
saying
i don't disagree with your change in
direction on that it's
i just give them the money or i wouldn't
yeah and i just call it call it
yeah rather i like your advice better
than mine
this is the ramsey show